no I'm not you know it's not just an
instant this is a pattern of behavior
police tend to walk away even when they
face jurors that sympathize with the
killer not with not with the murder the
victims of terror ages amadou diallo in
New York shot 41 times in the back on
arm by police it's a dilemma drilled in
the rectum to the nearly bled to death
by police inside the police headquarters
it's oscar grant in oakland california
it's Michael Brown in Ferguson Missouri
and there needs to be some kind of
commitment by our government to fourth
American secret protection and stop
these acts of terror do you believe that
if it was a white man running away they
would not have been shot in this way
when the men shot in the anyway there's
no evidence of it and as a matter of
fact if if I may have been shot why
should be protesting be more on the
consistent we should all black and white
alike protests against the mr relativity
against the inconsistent against the
meanest of it invariably these flight
police who killed black men walk away
free and we deserve better of course we
haven't had a trial the police officers
just been charged at this stage but how
do you believe a trial of what was that
one day I'll try well you hope there is
a trial but what we find in ribbon is
that the juries tend to set the killers
free whether it's immaterial amid givers
what it was are the Trayvon Martin of
what it is the aloe in New York of what
it is Michael Brown in Ferguson that
tend to be a kind of a sudden setting
them free which is a which compounds of
the Dagon if at all and we imagine maybe
Charlie time and then being handcuffed
while bleeding to death do you think
this should be a death penalty case well
it should be recording they'll have to
change state lift this is not death
penalty it could change death-penalty
law because by n is in the standard of
the lawyers it is he would face the
death penalty oh I'm not for the death
penalty oh I don't think it solves
anything I would prefer
without parole but if he does not get
the death penalty they can take it off
the books the point is often made by
people after these incidents that in
fact it's black on black crime which
claims many more lives killings in that
area what is your response to that my
response is basically in South
Carolina's Twitter powers in
african-american 75 some of the
prisoners are african-american they do
prison labor they make products in
prison for profits the whole criminal
justice system blast it more time for
the same crime so when something happens
that is as as blatant as being shot in
the back eight times it captures our
attention but you go to South Carolina's
prisons then look at the prison labor
force but this this whole season of
killing is now unlike we came out of
slavery in 1865 after 246 kids in
slavery that they Unleashed us they
Unleashed us to the hands of the former
slave masters they're more than 4,000
mentions of black men between 18
eighteen nineteen fifty-four thousand
plus lynchings at the church on Sunday
and that cool houses why do you think
this is happening now in 2015 I'm not
sure that the reaction office based upon
ignorance and fear hatred violence
President Barack resolve a great
leadership swing America how they lived
together when you grow these ballgames
in the we can we play ball together and
we learn to live together in that
context because we have the playing
field is even and the rules of fan the
goals are clear we do quite well when
the fill is uneven why is insecure and
seem to gain some advantage some social
and send some psychic gratification of a
killing black people and we must we
cannot stop them from wanting to do it
but a lot of the law must be a deterrent
we're dead getting more black people to
join the police forces would that be one
solution well that tents at ten would
tend to bounce at more blacks and more
Latinos or more women between the mega
please for us but even that they have to
be better trained and meet more
sensitive because whether you're black
or white somehow the bet the badge and a
gun affects people's sense of all power
and they don't and their power is not
all this limited power and the job is
protecting to serve not to be judge and
jury and kill people so what do you
believe that the authorities it's an
internet its international embarrassment
for the whole world's watching and what
do you believe that the authorities
politicians in America can do now to
stop these sort of incidents happening
again well the protests against the
killings of like fights must join the
March make this a moral issue not just a
racial issue I mean it is immoral or
four flights to kill blacks blacks give
advice no one should kill anybody but it
seems to be as if we have the burden of
proof when we are beaten and kill even
on camera we can be on camera and with a
jury and still the killer's walk free
that is what it's so disheartening about
the whole proposition this is state
execution this as an act of terrorism
months to deal with as we would deal
with in the terrorists Reverend Jackson
thank you for joining us from Chicago
thank you